il y a quelques jours éclater une
terrible affaire celle du politologue
olivier duhamel accusé par sa belle
fille camille kouchner d' actes
d'inceste sur son frère jumeau victor sy
très vite tout le monde s'est ému de ces
révélations beaucoup parlent de la fin
d'une omerta
voilà trente ans que de nombreuses
personnalités proches d'olivier duhamel
aurait fermé les yeux sur ces pratiques
pour le protéger à la lumière de ces
accusations olivier duhamel a quitté ses
fonctions au sein de la fondation
nationale des sciences politiques nos
six à europe 1 il faut aujourd'hui
l'objet de vives critiques de toutes
parts dans les médias pourtant un homme
a décidé de prendre sa dépense en
dénonçant le traitement auquel est
soumis olivier duhamel
il s'agit du philosophe alain
finkielkraut qui sur lci a déclaré y at
il eu ou non une forme de répression
réciprocité on vous tombe immédiatement
dans ce parce qu'on parle d'un enfant de
reals à leur bord on parle d'un
adolescent on parle de la même chose
une sortie qui a créé la polémique sur
les réseaux sociaux d'après une
information de télérama alain
finkielkraut aurait été écarté de
l'antenne de lci alors polémique alain
finkielkraut
êtes vous choqué par ses propos tenus
sur lci on va revoir sa sortie qui n'est
pas du tout passé regarder ce que fait
la justice aussi c'est qu'elles
recherchent le cas dans sa singularité
et là on ne peut pas bons on n'a pas les
éléments et quand on essaye de le faire
c'est à dire on dit mais yat il consent
y at il eu consentement à quel achat
commencer y at il eu consentement
y at il eu ou non une forme de
réciprocité
on vous tombe immédiatement dans ce
parce qu'on parle d'un enfant de et à
l'erreur on parle d'un adolescent on
parle d'un athlète c'est la même chose
c'est pas la même chose et en plus même
pour spécifier le crime
il faut savoir si les consentements ou
non nicolas pernikoff alors c'est assez
immonde mais surtout le problème c'est
que la révélation de camille kouchner
devient plus grave que l'acte cancer
voit ce genre de choses c'est à dire
qu'elle a eu ce courage là bas si je
suis désolé ça s'est passé dans les
années 80 bon même bernard kouchner j'ai
toujours pas compris pourquoi depuis les
années 80 il a par agir je vous le dit
entre nous parce que ça arrive à mon
enfant je suis désolé moi je réagis il
ya plus de 50 personnes qui étaient au
courant aurélie filippetti à l'époque
ministre était au courant elle était au
courant
voyez aujourd'hui camille kouchner elle
se retrouve attaqué de partout
n'appauvrisse à ce qu'elle a fait cette
révélation
une fois encore c'est la victime qui
s'en prend plein la tête je trouve ça
mais ignoble c'est vrai que moi je
soutiens à fond
kouchner très bien sûr vit des moments
très difficiles je vous le dis qui a
fait cette révélation qui a écrit un
livre bon vraiment de nombreuses années
après et qui s'en prend plein la gueule
temps après c'est incroyable à jeudi et
on soutient à fond
camille kouchner on pense fort à elle et
ça doit pas des moments faciles pour
elle aujourd'hui parce que non seulement
de se souvenir de ce qui s'est passé
voilà ça doit pas être facile mais en
plus aujourd'hui de s'en prendre plein
la gueule
quarante ans après ccc incroyable
incroyable
oui d'autant que bernard kouchner en
fait avait été le co signataires de la
pétition qui avait écrite par matzneff
donc ça c'est quand même le grave
c'était dans les années 70 en 77 avaient
été repris par dans le monde dans
libération et c'était en fait une
pétition qu'ils disent exactement ce que
vient de dire que quelques routes c'est
à dire que effectivement les enfants à
partir de l'âge de 12 13 ans peuvent
être su finalement la garde de leur
libre a même pas envie d'entendre parler
mais ça c'était ça alors je n'ai fait
partie des cosignataires donc c4 à grave
alors on va nous parler de ça parce que
c'est vrai que ça fait énormément réagir
aujourd'hui bien entendu c'est des
propos qui me choque et qui nous choque
profondément et paraît donc il a été
écarté
ça pour l'instant de l'antenne d'elle
saisie